hi there steve again it's the last day
of the year
i'm still in england visiting with my
son and his family
uh
as often happens i think about language
learning i'm
certainly spending a fair amount of each
day um an hour or two anyway
with my farsi
occasionally looking back at my arabic
which i'm going to get back to when i
get back to vancouver
and today i want to talk about patience
patience and language learning because
actually the reason is because my
daughter-in-law said to me she said
steve you're not a very patient person
how can you
be so interested in language learning
and it's true i'm not patient i can't do
you know things with my hands like i had
a friend who bought balsa wood and cut
it up into small pieces and built boats
and then
slid them into bottles and then
carefully pulled the sails up so they
had a sailboat inside a bottle i mean i
couldn't possibly do that i think my
stomach would be all tied up in a knot i
can't sit there and do things patiently
like that
and so i kind of have come to the
conclusion that using the word patience
for
language learning is a bit misleading
it's more a matter of perseverance and
energy when i
you know day after day after day
listen and read and occasionally use the
language that i'm learning i'm just
going at it with perseverance and energy
i know that eventually it's going to get
me to my goal
it's like jogging or cross-country
skiing is it's it's an activity that
requires
you know endurance
and determination to stay with it
it's not so matter so much a matter of
patience
and you have to let things go like i it
doesn't bother me
that i forget things it doesn't bother
me that i
can't say things that i don't understand
things that i get the rules wrong or
make mistakes none of that bothers me i
just keep going it's like i'm
cross-country skiing or jogging i'm
going at it with energy every day i go
at it
i go at it because i know that
eventually i will reach my goal and
maybe that's why
you know i don't have the patience to
practice golf for example forever on the
range because i don't think i will
really improve but i know from
experience that as long as i keep
putting in the time
and i apply myself with energy to
language learning i will eventually
reach my goal
and
i think
it's important also
maybe this is a type of patience not the
patients where you sit there and do
things that are very tedious and
painstaking
but the patience to say that you know
when you start with a language you know
in that first
few weeks
you achieved tremendous uh uh success in
a way
you're all of a sudden able to say
things
you can say hello how are you
all kinds of things in a new language
it's a feeling of great success and then
you discover that to actually reach a
level where you understand what people
are saying
you know where because people are not
going to direct their conversation at
you in the few words that you know
people are going to talk about a variety
of things
to reach a level where you can
understand people understand movies and
read comfortably takes a long long time
so really
what is required
in a way perhaps it's a form of patience
but not the kind of patients that i
don't have
it's more a matter of staying with it
perseverance
energy
belief that you can get there
and of course considering it worthwhile
you have to consider it worthwhile or
you're not going to put that energy and
that perseverance into the task so it's
not the sort of painstaking patience
that's required it's continuing
commitment and a belief that you're
going to get there and so maybe that'll
be my new year's resolution but i don't
need to make that new year's resolution
because i have that level of commitment
but any of you who
at some level want to become fluent in
another language and
you know
occasionally sort of stop doing it or
lose confidence or get frustrated maybe
your new year's resolution should be to
commit yourself with energy to staying
with the task regardless
don't rely on patience rely on energy
and perseverance okay then and happy new
year to everyone bye for now
it suddenly dawned on me that i should
perhaps end up
the video in a few different languages
so uh
bono rosanne uh
i don't know that's good enough for now
bye for now
[Music]